R
UNDER JOE BIDEN AND
ANTHONY FAUCI.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE, THE
HOST OF "LIFE LIBERTY LIVE IN,"
THE AUTHOR OF TEN SOLID WEEKS IE
BEST-SELLING BOOK IN THE
COUNTRY, THE NUMBER ONE SELLING
BOOK FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR,
AMERICAN MARXISM, THE GREAT ONE,
I CALL HIM, MARK LEVIN.
GREAT ONE, I WILL LET YOU JUST
TAKE IT FROM HERE BECAUSE I
CAN'T NAME A SINGLE THING
JOE BIDEN IS DOING THAT IS
WORKING.
MAYBE YOU CAN.
>> NO, I CAN'T.
THANK YOU, SEAN.
WHAT IS GOING ON IS AMERICAN
MARXISM.
THE BETTER CALL IT WHAT IT IS,
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
SPECIFIC THAT IS ILLUSTRATIVE OF
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE OPEN BORDERS THAT
VIOLATES FEDERAL STATUTES,
NOBODY IS HOLDING ANY HEARINGS
ON THAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE
THAT JOE BIDEN IS VIOLATING THE
LAW.
JOE BIDEN HAS PUT IN PLACE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY THROUGHOUT
THIS GOVERNMENT, VIOLATES, IN MY
VIEW, THE EQUAL PROTECTIONS PART
OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT AND THE
1964 CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
THIS GENDER IS HIM, WHICH
VIOLATES THE RIGHTS OF LITTLE
GIRLS AND WOMEN WHO PARTICIPATE
AND ATHLETES -- ATHLETICS AND SO
FORTH.
YOU CAN SEE HOW THEY ARE TRYING
TO LEGISLATE IN SECRET.
THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED PROGRESSIVES AND
MODERATES WORKING ON A DEAL.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE CUT OUT
AS WE, THE PEOPLE.
WE ARE NOT INVOLVED IN THIS
DEAL.
THEY KEEP THREATENING THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE
SUPREME COURT, OF COURSE.
WE HAVE MURDER THROUGH THE ROOF.
WE HAVE OUR ENEMIES ON THE MOVE.
COMMUNIST CHINA, FETISHISTIC
RUSSIA, THE ISLAMIC REGIME IN
TEHRAN, AND OF COURSE THE
INBRED THEY ARE IN NORTH KOREA,
AND WHAT IS THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FOCUSED ON?
MAKING INFLATION WORSE, SPENDING
TRILLIONS MORE, AND THE
NANCY PELOSI HAS SET UP A LITTLE
SOVIET TYPE OF BUREAU CALLED THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE, WHICH SHE
ONLY ALLOWED PEOPLE ON THE
COMMITTEE WHO ALREADY DECIDED
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS GUILTY OF
SOMETHING.
AND SO, WE HAVE REPROBATES ON
THIS COMMITTEE LIKE LIZ CHENEY.
I REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE USED TO
TALK ABOUT WANTING HER FATHER IN
PRISON.
YOU REMEMBER THAT, SEAN?
I REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE ARE VERY
UPSET AND SAID THAT HER FATHER
HAD LIED ABOUT THE INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION, AND I DON'T
REMEMBER ANY SPECIAL COMMITTEE
PUT TOGETHER TO INVESTIGATE ANY
OF THAT.
LIZ CHENEY IS NOT INVESTIGATING
WHAT HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN.
SHE IS NOT INVESTIGATING ALL THE
MS-13 AND DRUGS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
SHE'S NOT INVESTIGATING THREATS
AGAINST THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
OR ANYTHING OF THE SORT.
SHE HAS LOST HER MIND.
SHE IS UNHINGED, AND I AM
PICKING ON HER SPECIFICALLY AS
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS A SOVIET
STYLE COMMITTEE SET UP BY
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE WHO IS
CHASING AFTER X PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE ONLY TIME OF REGIMES THAT DO
THIS SORT OF THING IS, MAO USED
TO DO THIS, OF STALIN COURSE
USED TO DO
THIS, CASTRO USED TO DO
THIS, NO LONGER IN OFFICE,
TRY TO USE THE POWER OF THE
GOVERNMENT, HAS ANYBODY EVENT
CHARGED ON JANUARY 6 WITH
INSURRECTION, THEY KEEP CALLING
THIS AN INSURRECTION, NOBODY.
HAS ANYBODY BEEN CHARGED WITH
SEDITION QUESTION WORK NOBODY.
CHEAP TREASON?
NOBODY, SO WHY DID THEY KEEP
CALLING IT AN INSURRECTION.
THE ONLY PERSON KILLED ON
JANUARY 6TH WAS AN INNOCENT
PROTESTER WHO WASN'T VIOLENT IN
THE LEAST.
THE FBI ALREADY SAID THERE IS NO
PLOT, SO WHAT IS THIS
COMMITTEE THAT NANCY PELOSI HAS
PUT TOGETHER?
WHAT IS THIS COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
DOING?
WELL, IT IS THE WORST ATTACK ON
OUR DEMOCRACY AND HISTORY.
NO IT'S NOT.
THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH, IT IS WHAT HAPPENS
EVERY DAY IN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
AND THEIR SURROGATES AND
MOUTHPIECES IN THE MEDIA.
THAT IS THE WORST ATTACK ON THIS
COUNTRY, OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM,
OUR REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT
INC. SYSTEM AND SO FORTH, THAT
IS THE GREATEST THREAT THAT WE
PLACE.
DID PEOPLE SEEK MERRICK GARLAND
TESTIFY TODAY?
THEY HAVE TWO TYPES OF PEOPLE
THEY APPOINT IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION, RADICAL MARXIST
KOOKS AND EVIL TYPES.
HERE YOU HAVE MERRICK GARLAND
THAT DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING THAT
IS GOING ON.
THERE WAS A REAL INSURRECTION OF
THE INTERIOR DEPARTMENT LAST
WEEK.
MERRICK GARLAND WAS UNAWARE OF
IT.
HOW IS HE UNAWARE OF IT?
THEY PUSHED THROUGH, THEY
INJURED A POLICE OFFICER, NOBODY
GIVES A DAMN WHEN THE PORTLAND
COURTHOUSE, A
FEDERAL COURTHOUSE WAS ATTACKED
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT WITH FIRE AND
ALL KINDS OF STUFF, WHEN THE
POLICE WERE UNDER ATTACK, WHO
NANCY PELOSI CALLED
STORMTROOPERS, MERRICK GARLAND
SAYS "WELL, THAT IS NOT DOMESTIC
TERRORISM BECAUSE NOBODY THERE,
IT WAS HAPPENING AT NIGHT."
MEANWHILE, THEY GOT YOUR
PARENTS.
LIZ CHENEY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT?
NOT IN THE LEAST.
NOW WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM IN
THIS COUNTRY, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, WE HAVE A ROGUE
PRESIDENCY, WE HAVE A ROGUE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WE HAVE
AN OUT-OF-CONTROL
DEMOCRAT-CONTROLLED HOUSE.
BY THREE VOTES.
THE DEMOCRAT-CONTROLLED SENATE.
50/50.
BY THE LUCK OF THE CONSTITUTION,
THE VICE PRESIDENT BREAKS THE
TIE, AND WHAT DO THEY WANT TO
DO?
WHAT DO THEY SAY THEY WANT TO
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM.
WELL, ME YOU HAVE A CHOICE.
FREE-MARKET ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
YOU HAVE IN FREE COUNTRIES, THAT
RESPECTS INDIVIDUALS, CREATES
GROWTH AND WEALTH FOR INDIVIDUAL
HUMAN BEINGS TO WORK THEIR WAY
UP THE LADDER, OR YOU HAVE A
CENTRALIZED, MARXIST TYPE,
SOCIALIST ECONOMIC SYSTEM WHERE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., EITHER WHO
WORK FOR THE CIVIL SERVICE, NOTE
POLITICIANS DECIDE WHO GETS
WHAT, NOW WHERE DOES THAT WORK?
WHERE HAS THAT EVER WORKED?
DID IT WORK IN CUBA?
DID IT WORK IN VENEZUELA?
DID IT WORK ANYWHERE IT HAS
TRIED?
NO, AND THEY ARE DOING IT IN
SECRECY, AND BY GOD, WE HAVE TO
GET IT DONE BY OCTOBER 31ST,
WHY?
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO BE
AT SOME BIG MEETING, I THINK IT
IS A CLIMATE CHANGE MEETING,
WHEN HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE, SO WE'VE GOT TO
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM, OR GOVERNING
SYSTEM, DESTROY YOUR FREEDOM,
DESTROY YOUR LIFESTYLE BY
OCTOBER 31 SO JOE BIDEN CAN JET
OFF TO A CLIMATE CHANGE MEETING.
THIS GOVERNMENT IS
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
MANY OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE OUT OF
THEIR MINDS.
SOME OF THE REPUBLICANS ARE OUT
OF THEIR MINDS.
THE MEDIA ARE CORRUPT.
WE NEED A BIG FUMIGATION EFFORT
HERE.
SO IN THE NEXT ELECTION, WE HAVE
TO THROW THESE BUMS OUT, AND THE
ELECTION AFTER THAT, WE HAVE TO
THROW THIS DODDERING OLD FOO